KEVIN NELSON: Cloud Firestore
is a serverless NoSQL document
database that simplifies
storing, syncing,
and querying data for
your mobile and web
apps at global scale.
You may have heard of
that Cloud Firestore is
the next generation
of Cloud Datastore,
but what does that mean?
What makes it different?
And what should you do if you're
an existing Datastore customer?
I'm Kevin Nelson.
Find out answers to all
those questions and more
in this video.
Let's get the question I always
get asked first out of the way.
I want to start off by assuring
Datastore users that all
your existing Datastore
applications will continue
to work under Cloud Firestore
running in Datastore mode.
You won't have to
make any code changes
and you'll experience zero
downtime when your service is
automatically upgraded after
Cloud Firestore becomes
generally available.
So with that out of the
way, let's do a quick review
of what Datastore
is and then I'll
get into the new
capabilities being
introduced in Cloud Firestore.
Google Cloud Datastore is a
fully managed, NoSQL document
database, built for automatic
scaling, high performance,
and ease of application
development.
It was introduced with
Google App Engine--
Google's original serverless
development platform
that today, handles
the toughest workloads
from some of the world's
most popular apps.
Cloud Firestore
builds on the features
and massive scalability
of Datastore
while adding several
important new features.
The first thing to understand
is that Cloud Firestore
runs in two mutually
exclusive modes--
Datastore mode and Native mode.
In Datastore mode,
Cloud Firestore
runs all your existing
Datastore applications
and eliminates some of
Datastore's restrictions.
Cloud Firestore is built on
an entirely new back end that
brings the best of Google
Cloud's powerful cloud
infrastructure to existing
Datastore applications.
This includes
strong consistency,
automatic multi-region
data replication,
atomic batch operations,
and transaction support.
Perhaps even better,
Cloud Firestore completely
eliminates the entity
group transaction limits
that were present in Datastore.
Cloud Firestore has
no entity groups
and therefore, no
entity group limits.
You get all of these new
capabilities and compatibility
with Datastore when running
Cloud Firestore in Datastore
mode.
Cloud Firestore Native
mode has all the advantages
of Datastore mode,
but also contains
a number of new
features that make
it easier to power native,
mobile, and web apps, including
robust multi-device
synchronization, full offline
support, and a comprehensive
set of client libraries,
which support an
integrated storage
solution across Google
App Engine, Kubernetes,
and mobile devices.
You can learn more about this
using the link to my left.
It's important to
understand, though,
that Cloud Firestore Native mode
isn't compatible with existing
Datastore applications.
You'll have to set up a new
project with a new Cloud
Firestore database if you
want to use Native mode.
In either mode, Cloud Firestore
is a truly serverless database
service that eliminates
the need to think
about spinning up
virtual machines, data
replication, or scaling.
Should your app hit the
first page of Techmeme
and suddenly grow from
hundreds of QPS to millions,
Cloud Firestore
will automatically
scale to handle that
surge in traffic.
And congratulations.
The data model in Cloud
Firestore Native mode
is similar to the
Datastore data model,
but there are a few differences.
Data and Cloud
Firestore is organized
into documents and
collections, which
are similar to entities
and kinds in Datastore.
At the highest level, a
Cloud Firestore database
can have any number of
collections, which contain
any number of documents.
A document contains a
group of key value pairs
called fields in Firestore,
similar to properties
in Datastore.
Documents can also
contain sub-collections
of additional documents.
Notice the alternating pattern
of collections and documents.
Your collections and
documents must always
follow this pattern.
You cannot reference a
collection in a collection
or a document within a document.
Managing indexes
in Cloud Firestore
is also a little
different than how
they're managed in Datastore.
Like Datastore, Cloud
Firestore requires
an index for every query.
Firestore automatically
creates an index
for every document field.
Compound queries
require that you first
create a composite index
that maps to the range
clause of your query.
These are easy to
manage directly
from the Firestore console.
You'll even be prompted to
create the composite index
the first time you
attempt a query that
doesn't have an existing index.
When you create a new
Cloud Firestore database,
you'll select which
mode you want--
either Datastore mode or
Firestore Native mode.
Consider this choice
carefully because you
won't be able to change the
mode once the database has
been created.
As I mentioned earlier, to
take full advantage of all
of the new capabilities of Cloud
Firestore like offline support
and device synchronization,
existing Datastore users
will need to set up a new
project with a new database
in Firestore Native mode.
This was a very
basic introduction
to the Cloud
Firestore data model.
You can learn more
in my colleague Todd
Kerpelman's video series,
Get to Know Cloud Firestore,
on the Google Cloud
YouTube channel and online
at cloud.google.com/firestore.
There you can learn
all about Cloud
Firestore's [? scheme-less ?]
data model and advanced query
capabilities.
OK.
So now you're probably
asking yourself,
Firestore sounds
great, but what does
it really mean for my existing
application using Datastore?
Great question.
During beta, Datastore
customers-- or really, anyone--
can try out Firestore by
creating a Firestore database
in a new project.
Select Firestore under
the Storage options
in the GCP console.
If you want to move existing
data into Firestore,
you can do so using the Managed
Export and Import service.
Once Cloud Firestore
has been launched
for general availability,
all Datastore projects
will be automatically
migrated to Firestore
running in Datastore mode.
The upgrade will be done
automatically for you
with no downtime and no
changes to your application.
Absolutely no action is
required on your part.
Migrating all
Datastore customers
will likely take a few months.
You'll be notified
when your migration is
scheduled to begin.
If that time isn't inconvenient
or you have a critical time
window where you don't want
your application to possibly be
impacted by the automatic
migration-- say Black Friday--
you'll be able to indicate
preferences via a Google form.
But again, you shouldn't
notice any differences
at all during or
after migration.
So now you may be wondering
whether your next project
should be built using Cloud
Firestore in Datastore mode
or Native mode.
In general, we recommend
building new applications
in Native mode so your app
can take advantage of all
Firestore's capabilities.
But keep in mind that
during the beta period,
Cloud Firestore
won't have an SLA.
And Cloud Firestore
in Native mode
may have some
restrictions on the number
of concurrent connections and
the maximum number of writes
per second.
Those caps may rise as
we get closer to GA.
Refer to the documentation
for the latest details.
So Cloud Firestore
in Native mode
lets you take advantage of
Firestore's full capabilities,
but may not be appropriate
for large, mission critical,
enterprise applications until
Cloud Firestore goes GA.
So to recap, Cloud Firestore
is the next generation
of Datastore.
All existing Datastore
databases will
be migrated to Cloud
Firestore running
in Datastore mode
beginning shortly
after general availability.
That migration will be
automatic and seamless.
Firestore in Native mode adds
powerful new capabilities
for web and mobile developers,
like comprehensive client
libraries, offline support,
and automatic device
synchronization.
I hope this video has given
you a better idea about some
of the new capabilities
of Firestore
and what it means for
your existing Datastore
applications.
You can find lots more
information about Firestore
on the Google Cloud YouTube
channel and in the online docs.
You'll find those
links right next to me.
Thanks for listening.
[MUSIC PLAYING]